[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime up
drawer and today we are going to be
talking about every fight that took
place in the first season the seven
deadly sins except there's a catch I can
only use ten words to describe the fight
before we get started make sure to smash
that like button and subscribe for more
seven deadly sins and if the videos
aren't enough you can follow us on
instagram at anime uproar for daily
seven deadly sins posts and
conversations the Instagram has been
crushing it recently so definitely check
us out at anime uproar on Instagram and
help us keep the momentum going and if
you're interested in rocking seven
deadly sins inspired merch you won't
find anything better than anime uproar
calm we are selling original and epic
shirts like Eskin or praise the Sun
meliodas feel the wrath demon king all
hail the king and the son of Mele Otis
and Elizabeth our Sun of wrath shirt you
definitely won't find something like
this anywhere else so be sure to check
it out at anime out Broadcom the
collection is constantly being updated
so you never know what will pop up next
but I can't tell you that a bond shirt
and another very special one is in the
works and they may even be available by
the time you're watching this video let
us know in the comments if you have any
shirt ideas that you'd really love to
see happen and like other people's
comments if you agree in regards to this
video and is supposed to be
significantly less serious than most
I've tried this salad video before with
every ma che character explained in ten
words or less and I was very happy with
that one
make sure to let me know how you like
the style in the comments it will be up
to you guys if I do this type of video
for season two and even season three of
the seven deadly sins so if you want to
see those make sure to show your love by
liking and commenting and without
further ado let's jump into it twe go
cuts down a forest to counter cue the
memes you there how dare you survive
without my say-so
Electric Spears sent back and forth
winner guilt thunders Oh peach hair
meliodas let's guilt under her tongue
the an sends him blasting off bugs
attack and creep the n out thank God for
Earth bed
goal stop the runaway shaves him and
gets naked instead oh look a broken
sword never touch the sword if I can't
beat Mellie Otis I'll stab our doctor
the aunt and meliodas fight each other
cuz genjutsu bro
did you just hurt the MCS girlfriend
your [ __ ] you only capture me because
I'm a masochist your [ __ ] sounds pretty
nice
I'll see your dog and raise you a
demonic dragon speared by Peter Pan
immortality gets me off the hook I
didn't kill your sister
I [ __ ] her I mean one minute 37
seconds later
law remember one
zopi king Killa no wonder my dad thinks
I'm a disappointment
never fear Kings here not me kill the
French woman no fair
why the huge muscles never win an anime
go to go kill I want to be the MC I'm
even an airbender the mortal plane can't
contain so much power first a kid and
now a girl but my muscles muscles won't
help you against the last airbender
[Applause]
I bet all of my life savings on King and
just when you thought it was over demon
powers I love a woman that can kick my
ass
you killed your people no I didn't okay
I quit
Mellie Otis hits a girl the ants clothes
are in trouble
Jericho wants bond to take
responsibility are tied the most LP
being in this universe I'll know a
surprise it does psych get rekt bish my
hand
luckily magic stencil beans grow back
limbs it's halftime surprise I'm your
old friend now let me kill you seriously
how did halgrim manage to pull this off
the greatest earthbending I've ever
witnessed
bt-dubs I'm gonna find a trumpet and
resurrect your sister can't be gila
splits mountain in half with a twig I
want two monsters head here you go Jill
Dale I can't kill Dale
Mellie Otis kill Dale sure looks like
BOM got caught demon handed
now you see her now you don't I hate
magicians we witness a truly epic full
counter hawk actually proves to be
useful result King comes away with the
bloodiest of noses this is boring
I'll make them wanna Gus why bro I'm the
King Arthur my survival is 100%
guaranteed earthbending sense halgrim
blasting off but drape is a sword
penetrates DeeAnn you can break his neck
but he'll [ __ ] your mind the explosive
hurricane combo attack is not very
effective Dreyfuss 1 no go Thor 1 no
Dreyfuss one King takes damage to
protect the an legit a heartwarming
moment I almost killed the an but still
best friends of course
surprise attack ya know now talk or die
you plebeian blond hair green eyes the
finger he's a Super Saiyan
whoa Hendrickson called Arthur a boring
kid with a sword
Mele Otis is getting triple teamed and
it doesn't look pretty
my name is Gill Thunder you killed my
father prepare to die a perfect
introduction for a sexy Opie character
delicious pwnage damn Vivien you want
crazy-ass bit a horn told me to kill you
I feel you because you're my best friend
I'll kill you again again rapist powers
up an ultimate attack and hits Elizabeth
[ __ ] bond and differently holds a naked
Jericho our guys win the seven deadly
sins
they said the title of the anime and the
anime the seven deadly sins team-up
we've all been waiting for
Dora go
who Oded Hendrickson shoots up some
great demon blood Hawk sacrifices
himself how to win a fight
brutally injure your best fighter
[Music]
it's your sing and that is it for
today's video we definitely saw a lot of
good fights in the first season of the
seven deadly sins although they do get
more epic as the series goes on in the
first season some of my favorite fights
include the twee go fight because of its
historic significance the bond versus
Jericho fight because of how funny it is
and how Jericho ends up totally falling
for bond actually like Jericho a lot
because of the way if she behaves with
bond as the series goes on definitely
one of the best unrequited loves in the
series the second bond versus Mel Yoda's
fight was amazing because of the
backstory and emotions involved blonde
is torn between the love of his life and
his best friend and Melly Otis being the
amazing friend he is actually
understands where he's coming from and
still considers him to be his best
friend this is definitely one of the
best romances in anime and bond
definitely goes on to more than make up
for his attempt to kill Melly Otis later
on lastly I gotta go with Melly Otis vs
Hendrickson because that revenge counter
was epic and the perfect way to defeat
the final boss of the first season let
me know which was your favorite and why
in the comments also let me know how you
like this video and if you would like to
see similar videos for season 2 and the
upcoming season 3 definitely drop a like
if you enjoyed the video if you haven't
be sure to subscribe for more 7 Deadly
Sins videos be sure to follow us on
instagram at anime uproar where I'm
putting in a lot of work to provide
daily 7 Deadly Sins content often for
posts a day for you guys so definitely
check us out there a big thank you goes
out to our awesome patrons especially to
a pro tear patrons keelon and the one
and only gilgamesh and are the one tear
patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans infused silver aloe lawn optim
Maddie Mac 239 and a 17 FF DP thanks so
much for your ongoing support if you get
value from the stuff we do consider
supporting us for as little as $1 a
month over on our patreon if you become
a patron your name will appear in future
videos along with these amazing people
right here and if you're interested in
rockin 7th at least inspired merch you
won't find anything better than
Annamayya procom we are selling original
and epic shirts like Eskin or praise the
Sun Mele Otisfield Arab Stephen King all
hail the king and our newest edition
featuring the son of mellitus and
Elizabeth our Sun of wrath shirt you
definitely won't find something like
this anywhere else so be sure to check
it out at anime our procom and be on the
lookout for that Bond shirt that's in
the works and more they may even be
available by the time you're viewing
this video thanks again and until next
time see you space cowboys
[Music]